[Music]
[Music]
I'm Ken Campbell on the director of the
news office man today's session has
become a embargoed private briefing for
the night science journalism fellows at
MIT the embargo is for 11:00 a.m.
Eastern Daylight Time on Tuesday May 2
which means that it should not appear in
any publication anyplace in the world
before then and we've been getting great
cooperation from the press to adhere to
this embargo we've used this embargo
because this is a very complex story and
it's not one that you could just whip
off in a half an hour so you need to
have some time to look at it and study
it and then write a more comprehensive
story than isn't ordinarily available
under deadlines so I'd like to turn the
proceedings over to Michael to to zoast
the chairman of the Commission and first
Paul Gray will the president of MIT will
speak and introduce professor tutus us
good morning and thank you for coming
we're here today because we have an
urgent message to convey to convey to
America to its financial and industrial
community and to the millions of
Americans who rely on industry for their
livelihoods the message is that American
productivity is slipping even though the
United States is still the most
productive nation in the world the
weaknesses in American industry
concerned the way people think cooperate
invest manage and organize themselves as
well as the ways they become educated
use technology learn a new job and
interact with government we need to
rethink the way we do business and the
way we live in the world international
industry is driving along a highway of
many lanes the u.s. is ahead right now
but we're driving in the slow lane other
nations are speeding along behind us and
somewhere about the zoom past why is MIT
concerned as a science-based University
concerned with the education of engineer
and scientists MIT is deeply involved in
industry in science technology and
productivity we believe manufacturing is
absolutely essential to this nation's
economic future technology is the main
engine that drives the economy that's
the message MIT economist Robert Solow
has been teaching for 30 years the
problem of us productivity has been
studied by economists by social
scientists by engineers and by
scientists but up to now no one has
thrown them all together in a room to
thrash out this problem to study it from
the factory floor on up in the United
States in Europe and in Japan and to see
what MIT and other universities might do
about it that's why I appointed 16 MIT
faculty from the schools of science
engineering from the Department of
Economics and from social sciences to
this committee in November 1986 and
asked them to wrestle with this problem
until they came to a shared perspective
a common view about the problem and
about what might be done about it
I should note that this is the first
such effort we've undertaken at MIT at
least since World War two and perhaps
going back much earlier than that
we have with us today professors Michael
Dirr toussis Richard Lester Robert Solow
Suzanne Berger and Lester Thurow six of
the 16 commissioners Michael Dirr
toussis the chairman of the Commission
is professor of computer science and
electrical engineering and director of
the MIT laboratory for computer science
he's played a major role in fostering
cooperation between industry and
universities in the computer field and
he's been a leader in innovative
curriculum development in computer
science made in America
regaining the productive edge reports on
the conclusions of this commission what
MIT and other leading universities
should do to contribute to improving US
productivity and what industry must do
to get us back in the fast lane now
professor tertullus will give you a
20-minute summary of two years of work
which involved more than 75 people
he will then introduce the other
panelists who are here and we will try
to respond to your questions Michael
thank you Paul
good morning ladies and gentlemen the
message that we are in trouble is by no
means shared today nor was it shared
when we started our work by the people
of this nation
some people said then as they say today
that the u.s. is in big trouble they say
we've lost automobiles
we've lost textiles they say we've lost
consumer electronics and steel
they also say that US products are
becoming expensive and of lower quality
compared to foreign products our annual
trade deficit is huge at a hundred and
twenty billion dollars and the United
States productivity is growing slowly
but there are others especially our
leaders who tell us that we're second to
none and it is true that while US
productivity is growing slowly it is
nevertheless the highest in the world
also unemployment is low and our plants
are working at close to full capacity so
who is right are we in trouble or are we
okay as the president told you the
verdict of this commission after two
years of work is that the United States
industrial performance is indeed in
serious trouble and this matters a great
deal because if we do not mend our ways
all Americans will pay the price in
terms of our standard of living but to
correct this problem we must first
understand it unfortunately if you
string together all the accounts in the
press and all the scholarly studies that
report on this issue and on the
weaknesses of American industrial
performance you get a list so large that
it is unbelievable
so we set out to separate the important
from the unimportant in our own way we
took a different approach from most
other studies that treat the US economy
like a box with knobs that you turn to
control exchange rates or interest rates
it's not that we do not believe in
macroeconomic factors we just don't
think they're adequate to explain or
correct the nation's productivity
problems so we based our work on a
bottom-up study of these 8 industries
which are shown here along with the
trade balance
they include winners and losers and
together they account for some 28% of
United States manufacturing we split
ourselves into eight groups and carried
out 550 interviews in three continents
concentrating on what happens at the
factory floor in the office and in the
boardroom we also form the ninth group
which looked at education both at school
and at work we then took all these
results from the eight studies of the
industries in the ninth group of
Education and we pull them together and
searched for common patterns of
weaknesses none of the weaknesses that
emerged from this bottom-up study will
be new to you since as I said earlier
every conceivable weakness has been
brought forth what is new in the MIT
results is which of the many reported
weaknesses emerged as actual patterns
from this bottom-up study they are only
six
first weakness outdated strategies in
the best US and foreign companies mass
production has given way to short runs
of sophisticated high quality customized
products yet we have found that the bulk
of US companies still cling to an
inflexible mass production strategy that
worked well in the days of Henry Ford
workers are still treated like cogs in a
wheel that must be kept turning no
matter what the wheel of production this
older rigid system turns out to be less
productive than the newer more flexible
ones so that is one of our outdated
strategies clinging to mass production
but there is a second we are also
parochial we still look to the United
States as the sole source of everything
and particularly of Technology US
companies for example were late in
introducing the basic oxygen furnace or
the qaol bata measuring system in
textiles both were foreign technologies
we also assume that others share or at
least they should share our tastes and
the way we do business as did one of our
companies that we studied that shipped a
huge quantity of sweatshirts to Europe
expecting that they would sell as well
as they were selling at home and found
out of course that they did not but let
us move on to the second weakness short
time horizons now here is a familiar
pattern a famous American electronics
company faces competition at the low end
of its markets say the transistor radios
from a Japanese company or companies
it abandons that market to Japan it
holds on to its higher-end commercial
electronics product and then it turns
around and it buys a rental car company
or a finance company now they do this
because they believe that it shows a
higher return on investment higher ROI
meanwhile the Japanese company builds
its knowledge and expertise in this area
builds up market share holding profits
low or zero and eventually assault the
higher-end commercial electronic
products of the American company and so
it is that in consumer electronics where
we once produced 90% of what we consumed
we're now down to 4% by not sticking to
their knitting as we call this behavior
US companies end up losing both
expertise and market share now it is
often said that the high cost of capital
is the culprit that pushes our companies
toward a short term orientation the
Commission agrees that this is a factor
but we have found other factors as well
for example these ROI calculations when
in error tend to favor the short term in
the investing strategies of fund
managers who control a lot of a stock of
these companies value companies with
short-term profits
third weakness technological weaknesses
in development and production the United
States is first in the world in
inventing new product transistors color
television VCRs were all invented here
yet none of these products or hardly any
of these products are made here today
and the products that we make for
example automobiles have a larger number
of defects in the case of cars almost
two to one compared to Japanese products
it's almost as if we've spent so much
energy inventing that there is none left
to convert our inventions into products
in fact we do spend two-thirds of our
industrial R&D money on the inventing
side and one-third on the processes that
make products out of these inventions in
Japan this ratio is reversed beyond that
our attitudes to favor invention over
production we glorify the inventor and
we feel that a career in manufacturing
spells sheer drudgery we tend to design
quickly and debug later whereas in the
best companies both here and abroad
people build quality into the design we
also look for breakthrough strategies we
look for that AHA that is going to solve
our problems and we do not believe so
much in the incremental steady gradual
improvements that are favored by the
world's best companies we even have this
word or this phrase in our culture we
say if it ain't broke yet don't fix it
fourth weakness neglect of human
resources first and foremost we neglect
education at the kindergarten through
twelfth grade level the United States a
nation that pioneered mass education is
now ranking through its students high
school students worldwide in various
exams from math to geography and reading
between 8th and 15th
among the nations of the world and this
slippage is happening at a very wrong
time when the new systems of production
called for greater technical literacy in
the workforce this educational problem
of the United States youth is perhaps
the biggest weakness that we face but
there is more
we also neglect our workforce we tend to
view labor as a cost factor to be
minimized rather than a precious asset
to be nurtured and developed let me
explain our vocational schools are not
effective and on-the-job training on
which our companies spent over 50 or 60
billion a year involves either remedial
training like reading and arithmetic or
following Jo around to learn how things
are done by contrast in Japan and in
Germany workers undergo systematic job
rotations that makes them broader more
flexible and more willing to learn new
skills as a result when a plant fails in
the United States some centralized team
has to be brought over to correct the
damage and that takes time and induces
delays in Japan and Germany most of the
time failures of plants are handled by
the operators because they've been
trained broadly enough to understand all
the aspects of their plant thereby
saving time and money
for their companies
fifth weakness failures of cooperation
we found this at several levels first
there are failures of cooperation within
our companies here is a pattern the
designers design a product they toss it
over the wall to the production people
the production people try to build it it
doesn't work very well they write some
Corrections toss it back over the wall
for redesign this ping pong goes on and
on and can be traced to induce delays in
the production process in copiers in
automobiles and another product we have
found these delays to amount to as much
as two to one compared to companies that
do not follow these practices but there
are other failures of cooperation there
are failures of cooperation between a
company and its suppliers in the u.s.
automobile business for example as in
other businesses we find in this country
thousands of suppliers who are as in the
best of companies both here and abroad
one finds hundreds of suppliers same
business also there is a difference in
the way we deal with our suppliers in
the u.s. the relationship is based on an
adversarial thing the contract and the
specter of potential litigation whereas
in the best companies the relationship
is one of cooperation and sharing a
mutual goal we also found failures of
cooperation among competing companies
now you would say why should competing
companies cooperate for one thing to
develop common standards in the
numerically controlled machine tool
business for example we have found that
in this country we had great difficulty
in agreeing on a language for these
machines to talk to each other
the Japanese had no such problem they've
got one company to construct the
controllers and they settled on the
language never mind that it wasn't the
best language it was common
and apparently we haven't learned yet
because in the area of computer networks
we have exactly the same problem today
we have one standard for almost every
company that we have that makes Networks
sixth weakness government and industry
at cross-purposes when we started our
study our friends from business told us
that too much government was what was
causing their difficulties and America's
productivity plight
now our industry studies did not bear
this out nor did they bear out the
opposite what we did find is that
government and industry are going their
own way following their own agendas of
Bolivia's to each other's needs and
aspirations
now here becoming depressed by all this
gloom let me say that in our industry
studies we were also heartened to find
common patterns of best practices those
companies that do as well or better than
their foreign adversaries in the
international arena since what we found
out is included in our recommendations
our recommendations of best practices or
imperatives if you wish I am going to
try to save time and move on now
studying the weaknesses in America as
well as the strengths isn't enough
because that takes us only up to now we
need to look at the future so the
Commission tried to identify future
trends that would govern business and we
came up with three broad such trends we
believe that the world will become even
more international than it is today and
therefore even smaller second people
will expect and will get higher quality
more sophisticated products third
technology and particularly information
technology biotechnology and material
technology will become more critical to
the production of goods
now these trends spell out a quickening
of the pace the need for US companies to
be more agile more flexible and more
sophisticated if we are to compete
effectively in the world now the MIT
commission combined what we learned from
studying these weaknesses the strengths
and the future trends we put them all
together to come up with our
recommendations there are five
imperatives that if followed by industry
by government and by the nation's
educational institutions will help
America regain its productive edge I
will describe them briefly and broadly
the book spells out what they mean for
each of the players namely industry
government and educational institutions
first imperative focus on producing well
the new way what do we mean by that for
one thing we mean that we must stop
putting finance ahead of production this
business of manipulating financial
instruments from one mirror to another
is no way to create new wealth and we
must focus as much attention and
production processes as we do today on
the inventing of new products our
managers too will no longer be able to
remain detached saying as they often do
today I can do anything
point me what do you want paper clips or
jet aircraft I can make it tomorrow's
best managers will need to know their
product intimately
second imperative cultivate a new
economic citizenship as we have seen the
old rigid system where each individual
worker and each supplier is a cog in
this large wheel of production and if
they don't behave you toss them so that
the wheel can keep turning that old
system of production works no more
employees must now be given greater
breadth greater responsibility and
broader on-the-job training in order to
be productive with the new sophisticated
and flexible systems of production and
since so much more is being asked of the
workforce they must also be rewarded
both with participation in the firm's
gains and with greater employment
stability but we can go beyond the
utilitarian notions that we need to
treat workers well so that they will
produce better which is true we can go
beyond that there is an unprecedented
opportunity here to give the United
States workforce a new sense of mastery
of their work environment a greater job
satisfaction and that's why we call it a
new economic citizenship third
imperative blend cooperation and
individualism when the stakes are high
we have shown that we can do both as do
the Boston Celtics or more seriously the
best of companies in the United States
now we can take some practical steps to
we can begin doing this by flattening
organizational hierarchies which now run
17 layers deep from the boss to the
lowest person in a company and we can
begin rewarding with bonuses both
individualism and cooperation in
companies
fourth imperative learn to live in the
world economy we must learn foreign
languages cultures and practices if we
are to compete in the world arena and we
must shop internationally for the best
technologies wherever they may happen to
arise we must also establish national
policies that will help us save for
productive investment and balance our
budget finally we should invest in the
future by investing in infrastructure
both old and new just as an example the
Commission thinks that we should begin
investing in a new national information
network that will be to information and
business in the 21st century what the
highway system was to the transportation
of goods in the economy in this century
let me now conclude with what the
Commission believes is an important
observation these five imperatives are
not a menu they are not a menu from
which you can pick and choose
they work together let's get them in
focus here they work together like a
well well-oiled mechanism to bring human
resources and Technology together into a
highly productive overall system in fact
this is the main reason that when we
studied the best practices in the u.s.
we found that they didn't diffuse as
widely as we thought they should I mean
if these companies are doing so well why
aren't their practices being copied we
believe that the reason is that those
companies that are doing so well
are doing most if not all of these
things as a result if another company
wants to imitate them they must undergo
so many changes and so many wrenching
changes that it's not easy and that's
why those practice are not diffusing now
in closing we have the MIT Commission
and industrial productivity belief that
industry government and the educational
institutions of the United States can
indeed pull together to carry out these
imperatives this will require a great
deal of effort and a considerable change
of attitude
but it must be done if we want to live
well we must produce well there are no
shortcuts on behalf of the Commission
thank you now as you ask questions
please identify yourselves and your
organization and may I ask the panel to
please come up we have no floor
microphones so we will have to rephrase
your questions and before we start let
me introduce panelists you've already
met president Paul Gray next to him is
Professor Robert Solow the Department of
Economics Nobel Prize winner in
economics 1987 next to him professor
richard lester for nuclear engineering
department professor lester was
executive director of the
and professor solo was vice-chairman on
your extreme right is professor less
thorough Dean of our Sloan School of
Management and ladies and gentlemen were
ready for your questions yes sir
the question is if we can describe what
would happen to America presumably the
standard of living of America that I
said would go down if these imperatives
are not met who would like to take this
question there are two things one is
that if your productivity is growing but
at a relatively slow rate it means that
parts of your population are gonna have
Falls in their absolute standard of
living and one of the interesting things
at the moment in the United States and
if you talk about plugging along you
look at what's been happening in the
last ten years if you take the group the
Department of Labor calls
non-supervisory production workers which
are about two-thirds of the American
workforce that groups real wage is 8
percent below its peak in 1972 and it's
currently falling at a rate of a little
less than 1% a year and that so if you
think of the bottom two-thirds of the
American workforce the answer is that
you should expect a slow decline in your
absolute standard of living the other
problem of course is if the rest of the
world is doing better you also get a
decline in your relative standard of
living and I suppose a good example of
that would be Great Britain where in
1900 they had the world's highest
per-capita income their income didn't go
down but now they have a standard of
living that's about two-thirds of that
of what would occur in the most advanced
developed countries like Germany of the
United States or Japan and so there are
two barreled answers that part of the
American population will suffer a
decline in their absolute standard of
living and most of the American
population would suffer a decline in
their relative standard of looy tax
question
what's the Commission able to identify a
system nation or government do we have a
nation or government that could act as a
model for what we are saying here
there's a short answer to that I don't
think the Commission in any way believes
that we ought to try to turn the u.s.
into Japan or in to West Germany or
anything of the sort we have our own
ways of operating our own culture our
own normal patterns of behavior we think
that some of them have become
unfunctional or doing us harm rather
than good and those can be changed
without altering the fundamental
character of the society will still play
baseball in the spring will still play
hockey in the winter and the u.s. will
look very much like the u.s. inside
factories and between corporations
that's where the difference is okay
apparently there is no victory
[Music]
I'm sorry I couldn't hear the somebody
rephrase it from the table please I
think the question is that these kind of
changes take time and if you're thinking
you better are we talking about a series
of changes over the next 10 years or the
next 20 years and how much time is there
to make these kind of changes is I
interpreted the question that was it
gentlemen anyone wants to take that
question
well I think the answer is that it this
is we are not talking about the sort of
change that happens one-one Thursday at
eleven o'clock in in the morning many of
the things that we've described that
Mike described have already started to
happen in in American industry and they
will we hope accelerate in the next in
the next years there's not a cliff that
one falls over there's not a catastrophe
hanging in the out there on the edge
that one runs the danger of incurring
Lester pointed out that the the cost of
not doing this is is damaged to the
standard of living of our children and
damage to the relative position of the
United States in in the world not a
single catastrophic event but a
drawn-out process we start reversing
that tomorrow or in fact we have already
started reversing that last year in many
industries all right these imperatives
have different time constants in terms
of change that might occur in some cases
such as the
changing the the economic partnership as
it was described within a company
changing the way in which the workforce
is perceived managed used change can
begin rather quickly another aspect of
that of that related weakness which was
described by the Commission hinges on
the quality of education pre-college
education in the United States the fact
that that 20 percent roughly 20 percent
of the adult population are functionally
illiterate the fact that in
understanding of simple mathematics and
in science we tend to rag rank towards
the bottom and every comparison with
other industrialized nations it's going
to take a while to change that it's
gonna take some time to bring about
change in the quality of pre-college
education across the nation but it seems
to me we we need to be in on it rather
quickly
the book lists approximately eleven or
so I think ways in which business could
undertake these imperatives translate or
interpret these imperatives I'm not
gonna mention them here all just mention
a couple for example flattening the
organizational hierarchies that can be
done overnight our large companies can
reorganize themselves and they do
overnight developing and adopting new
measures of quality for example instead
of measuring the quality only in terms
of profits one could adopt explicitly
measuring the quality of the products
and in keeping track of it integrating
the functions of design production
marketing this has already been
happening in the best US companies the
teams in the pro printer project at IBM
and in the Ford Taurus project so there
are many of these ways of attacking
early there are others as president gray
said that'll take much longer especially
in the area of Human Resources more
questions
[Music]
quality
to apply
to look for suppliers work
the question is how to reconcile the
recommendation that we shop for the best
technology wherever it may arise with a
huge trade deficit of the United States
and the answer is directed to me so I
will I will try to answer it putting
restrictions doing protectionism is is
really no way to solve the problems
before us because it invites retaliation
and it invites all kinds of
complications that later haunt everybody
and I think the the essence of your
question if there's one answer to your
question that's protectionist that's
what I would say about it so we have no
alternative but to go for what we've
been preaching throughout the birth of
this country which is a free market
economy and buying the best technologies
wherever they arise this is not where
the problem is the problem in America is
in converting the great inventions in
which were number one in the world into
high quality products and we simply must
learn to do that and that is what our
imperatives are directed to next
question yes
the question is how can the government
inspire the businesses to follow these
imperatives who would like to take this
responsibility in some sense that's the
responsibility of the press in the media
because one of the things you're
supposed to do is bring to the American
public or any public in the world some
view of what the rest of the world looks
like and one of the things we're talking
about here in some sense is that the
rest of the world has copied some of the
good things in the United States like
mass education and then they've upped
the intensity level and done it better
than we have traditionally done it which
means we've got up our intensity level
and kind of leapfrog once again and so I
think it's a real question of in some
sense are the media telling the average
citizen and the way in which the
opposition can understand it that his or
her world has changed and standard good
old American operating procedures that
used to work 30 years ago won't work
today simply because the world is
different and I don't think it's mr.
Bush that's going to solve this Bob
problem
[Music]
and respect for the use of the mass
media to increase scientific literacy
does the book have any specific
recommendation about how the mass media
could help increase scientific
interaction is that which the scientific
literacy scientific literacy technical
literacy I see yes it's a long book so
we have to do a little bit of scanning
one of the things look the problem is
very complex and and one cannot look at
the answer to your question as the
panacea but let me just cite a couple of
things the universities on the demand
side the universities are the ones who
take the students that come from the K
through 12 level and there we say that
we might increase our standards and
demand a higher preparation in technical
topics but that alone of course is not
enough something must be done on the
supply side on the teacher side gotta
motivate the students take into account
the demographic changes and the changes
in the ratio of the population that is
going to be here in 10-15 years so that
a lot more has to be done on that side
as well but there is one possibility the
other possibility that was discussed in
the book is lengthening the school year
which in America is now one of the
shortest among the school years in the
world
yes
it's a story which has been out for a
couple years that America's not the
changes are happening but they mean
the question is like to come back to the
same issue that this is not a new
message these are known things and what
really should be done what should
industry government do to really get
things going because they're so slow
I would like to ask the panel to
consider answer your question while hi
give you an answer to the statement you
made the assertion you made that this is
not new as I said none of the weaknesses
you heard is new because there have been
hundreds of weaknesses paraded in the
press but that is very much like a
person suffering from a large number of
diseases and so he is told because
everybody who comes by caesium sees that
he's sick and he says you've got disease
X the other person says he got disease Y
by the time they're done he hears that
he suffers from a hundred diseases and
then a doctor comes in and measures the
temperature and the blood and all the
good things and says you've got only
three diseases and then the patient says
I'll go away I've heard about these
diseases you know these other 50 people
told me about it now I want to really
contest the statement that these results
are not new the MIT results are very new
because they tell you which combination
of those things you've been hearing
forever matter as you study the problem
from the fact from the bottom up so I
think it is new and I think before that
at least we of the Commission faced this
myriad of recommendations and questions
and diagnosis and you really couldn't
find your way through there now with
that as a basis perhaps I think maybe -
first I'm going to reveal my age and
tell you that I remember when Rita
Hayworth was everybody's idea of a
beautiful movie star and and in my youth
there was a joke that we told a girl
says to her boyfriend what does Rita
Hayworth have that
don't have and the boyfriend thinks for
a minute and says nothing but she groups
it better our hope is that we have
grouped it better but now let me come to
the to the rest of of the question
somebody asked earlier and les answer
that question particularly what can the
government do to inspire the this sort
of change and I think that Lester gave
the right answer we are not anticipating
inspiration from the from the government
in in this respect the most American
corporations understand the problem that
they face and they need not so much
inspiration as a little bit of guidance
and some some energy I don't think that
les they're meant to suggest that there
is nothing that public policy can do to
to improve or speed-up or facilitate
this process there's lots of public
policy out there that's needed the
report does not spell out proposed
pieces of legislation or regulation or
anything of the sort we didn't think
that that was the right task for a group
of of MIT faculty but there one can
easily infer from what the what we've
written that policies that stimulate
saving and investment in the American
economy that make it easier for
corporations to take the long view to
commit funds for risky and long-term
development projects technological
development projects any such policies
and we all know what they are actually
would be useful the the federal
government in in this country has long
played a role in supporting and
providing incentives for research and
development activity both in
universities in nonprofit research
organizations and in corporations it
ought to be doing more and not only or
toward it to be doing more but I think
it's a fair in
from what we've said that we would like
to see the government support of Science
and Technology include support focused
at that part of technological
development that lies somewhat closer to
the commercial production end and not
simply basic research which is where the
government has specialized up until up
until now so I think there's you ought
not to think of this group as believing
that the no public policy could be
useful or even necessary for this
there's lots let me make an addendum to
it I think you know I probably was a
little unfair in my earlier answer
because I think we also need some
leadership from Washington and let me
give you a couple of illustrations you
remember back during the vice
presidential debates in this
presidential campaign that vice
president Quayle basically implied that
if people in Indiana grew Belgian endive
that was somehow unpatriotic because
somebody had claimed that you would make
more money but growing Belgian endive
than you would American corn when you
can think of Belgian endive if you'd
like it's a technology found abroad a
product which you can sell for a high
price and if you can grow Belgian endive
in Indiana and sell it for a lot more
money per acre than corn then you ought
to be growing Belgian endive but if
you're so myopic you say the only thing
Americans to do is grow corn of course
you're then in trouble and I think what
we need is is is some leadership at the
top that understands that we have a
problem now my impression is that I
think our leaders do understand we have
a problem but they have convinced
themselves that in order to get elected
you have to pretend that you don't have
a problem and I think what that does is
confuse the public horribly because you
read about all the problems in the press
and then during our political campaigns
our leaders all deny that there are any
problems and then if you're any average
person I think you end up just
conflicted do you say well maybe there's
some problems but but somehow these guys
are running the countries and they don't
think there are any problems or at least
that's what they say
and so I think you're one of the things
we have to do at the government level
let's put it out on the table what we
believe about these problems is supposed
to say that the only thing that sells to
the American public in an election
campaign is gross ranked opt
the book has nine points which are
recommendations to government the
translation of the question is who ought
to be the recipient of our message the
public or the more responsible people I
presume you mean corporate executives
government officials I think the answer
in the United States has to be both
because we don't quite have an
establishment in the sense that some
other countries have an establishment
that came to kind of some sense Ram
things down people's throat and so when
you say the American establishment or
the Japanese establishment I think
you're talking about very different
groups of people and what they can do
and since we don't have an establishment
in the sense that Japan has an
establishment I think a much broader
group of people have to be convinced
that change is necessary in the United
States than perhaps have to be convinced
in some other countries and of course
the other thing that is true in the
United States that you have to remember
that is not true for example in Europe
most Americans never leave the United
States nine out of ten don't leave the
United States and so they have no
experience with the rest of the world
and don't see these things firsthand
well if you're a European just when you
go on your vacation you're gonna see
some other countries be someplace where
somebody speaks a different language
where the refrigerator's don't look
exactly the same those kind of things
and so I think this problem of kind of
educating Americans as to what the rest
of the world is like and how it forces
them to adjust their procedures is much
harder simply because we are so large
and you know there are five million
Americans that go to Europe every summer
but they're the same five million every
year we have a couple more questions
here your first year
I think that some of the senses like
production and had the finest
so I think after this book and have
those suggestions how do you think you
could implement them like funding
committees with leading persons from the
educational institutions and industries
and government like to to form a living
group like to put three remain those who
share with you and also we here at MIT
that you are already thinking about okay
the question is what's the best way to
implement or how are we going to
implement what we preach in this book
professor Lester the question one of the
things that the report points out and
that Mike mentioned is that we have had
we have observed in a number of the
industries we looked at weaknesses that
we call downstream technical weaknesses
weaknesses in product design process
design manufacturing and to some extent
although not entirely that set of
weaknesses can be traced to developments
to an evolution in the way we think or
have thought about engineering education
in at MIT and at the other leading
research universities and technical
universities within the last couple of
years as you may have heard we have made
a number of attempts to rethink that to
some degree and one of the things we've
done is introduce a program a master's
program joined with Sloan and
engineering directed towards increasing
the production if you like of people
engineering and management oriented
people who know about and will practice
manufacturing that's one of the things
that
we've tried to do but in fact our report
calls for a broader approach to some of
these problems within MIT in which we
would hope that right across the
Institute more attention would be given
for example to production real
manufacturing production problems also
more attention as les was talking about
to the International aspects of this
problem so we think that there are a
number of things that we can do at MIT
and maybe other research universities
should also be doing to make us at least
more responsive to some of these
problems
this of course is what we should do at
home which comes first and we spell out
quite a bit of what MIT and other
universities should do insofar as
industry is concerned besides putting
out our book we're having a lot of
meetings with a commission and CEOs of
companies groups the alumni of MIT so
we're spreading the word that way and
insofar as government is concerned we
are having a briefing at the executive
branch next Monday and we're having a
briefing in Congress in the afternoon
were testifying before senators Kennedy
senator Kennedy's Committee on on
Wednesday I think we're doing the best
we can which a university can do which
is disseminate its results through the
media and through the written word yes
ma'am
yes we do we have several reactions and
perhaps there are friends but they're
running fairly positive in fact the back
of the book has quite a few endorsements
from industry we better wait until this
is out that see the other comments as
well yes sir situation as each other but
you could say this one looks at profits
ten years from now instead of next
quarter and does a better job this one
treats workers as an asset instead of a
cost the question is to give some
specific examples of the studies we've
done I'd like to call him professor
Lester striking comparisons that emerged
from from our work came out of the steel
industry where we looked at both
integrated steel companies large
companies that basically do everything
but also we looked at the we spent some
time visiting some of the mini mill
companies which have been quite
successful over the last several years
in grabbing market share from the larger
companies and we did see very striking
differences in many of these dimensions
one dimension in particular that I'd
point to would be the way these
companies handled human human resource
questions one of the most striking
pieces of evidence in this respect
concerned chaparral steel which is a
small minimal company located in Texas
in order to learn about what was going
on around the world in their particular
field and in in order to import the best
practices both organizational and
technical that company sent groups of
people including production workers and
maintenance workers as well as
white-collar people within the company
sent them around the world gave them
travel fund said you go out and learn
what you can about
what our best competitors are doing and
come back and implement them that
company also for example sent its
production workers out people that
worked on the on the line so to speak to
talk to their customers to find out what
those customers thought of their product
and what they could do to improve it
what once saw in this particular company
and I think this is an example that that
would apply in a number of other
industries what one saw was a kind of a
breaking down of some traditional
functional areas functional activities
within a company making the company more
open so to speak to the to the flow of
information from outside and this was a
fairly strong contrast from what we
observed in some of the older larger
steel companies let me just give you an
extension so you can see more examples
the second half of the book made in
America is full of various of these
examples in the eight industries and
three weeks from now we're publishing
through the MIT press the nine volumes
they're actually two volumes but there
are nine sets of working papers of the
commission which include all the
detailed examples so that you will have
an ample opportunity to get more of the
bottom-up material that drove us to our
conclusions so part of this is also just
kind of a mindset now this is not a
comparison so much among American firms
but if you look at the textile section
of this report the conventional wisdom
kind of the United States is textiles is
a low-wage industry and you can't
compete in textiles if you're not
mainland China and paying $2 a day the
problem with that conception is that
there is a very successful high wage
textile industry in a country like
Germany and it may be true in textiles
you can't do everything and pay high
wages but if you get very carefully put
it together in fact there's a very
viable reasonably large textile industry
that can be built that is survivable in
a high wage industrial country as the
Germans demonstrate and so the question
then is can you put that kind of thing
together in the United States and there
shouldn't there doesn't seem to be any
intrinsic reason because you can find
individual firms that are starting to
move in that direction but the problem
is you have to do it as a whole industry
you can't do it on an individual firm
basis because
if you got one firm that is very good at
making cloth that doesn't save the
industry you've also got other people I
gotta have other people who could put
together the garment part of it perhaps
the chemical part of it and so forth and
so you know it is possible to do some
things that work and if you have these
blinders that say that's impossible
you're just abandoned an industry it
shouldn't be fully abandoned we have
just a couple of minutes left so let's
see you had a question you they can't
survive as a company necessarily if they
try to to become US Steel tries to
become chaparral some of these changes
mean that there has to be a different
set of companies that we're going to add
new companies that are built on these
new principles or can the existing
companies make these changes
the question is of course since these
changes of the imperatives are so many
and so wrenching what does this mean how
are we going to be able to diffuse them
in in American industry they're gonna be
some countries that can't some companies
that can't change and will effectively
go out of business but you can find
examples of big companies that are
trying to make these kind of changes and
I think some reasonably successfully I
suppose one of the examples that would
be common today you know if you think
about Ford on the largest scale roughly
with this sort of thing in mind although
not precisely of course the details that
are in this book when the General Motors
Corporation decided to build a car that
they wanted to call the Saturn
they they decided to to build it almost
as an entirely separate company
different place a sort of self-contained
management simply to be almost
independent of the rest of the
corporation so if if even sort of the
arch typical big corporation like GM can
do that then I suppose other
corporations can do the same the famous
German luxury cars the mercedes-benz and
the BMWs and so you know it is possible
to recapture the these markets and you
see examples if you look at luxury cars
are down you can turn those things
around I think the question has to do
with the fact that there seemed to be
some deeply rooted American some
cultural aspects in American society and
how do we reconcile this with what we
are doing and what we advocate that we
should be doing right there is a
different mindset in this country about
economic beliefs is that the involvement
of the state in the economy I see I see
well I don't know one of our
distinguished economists I I think your
statement is basically right that we
like to pretend that we're pragmatist
but in some ways we are very dogmatic
and what comes to the idea that
government can't do anything well I
think we are extremely dogmatic and I
think that's a bit of dogmatism that
we're gonna have to modify for example
if you look at research and development
in every country in the world at least
half and usually two-thirds of the funds
one way or another come from government
and government plays a very important
role because of what economists know as
externalities and we're gonna have to
face up to some of those
now obviously the trick of any society
being successful over the long run is
can you change your dogmatism you may be
a crusader at every point in time but
you crusade for different things as the
decades roll along and I think that's
going to be the test over the next two
or three years is can we decide which of
these dogmas are really functional in
the 21st century and which of these
dogmas in some sense have to be
discarded to be successful in the 21st
actually no I think that part of it is
the easiest part of it government is the
sphere in which the human race has
developed the the greatest capacity to
say one thing and do another it is that
is not a vast but I think the the the
harder problem will be the what you
might describe as the culture of
Industry the notion in this country for
instance the trade unions and management
are bitter enemies and must always be
bitter enemies and concessions or
cooperation between them is assigned to
the rank-and-file that somebody is being
betray that that sort of thing the
notion that industrial operations have
to be simplified that the ideal way to
produce something is to a complicated
object is to break it down into the most
the most elementary bits so that an
uneducated person or even a primitive
robot can do it that's the sort of thing
I think will be harder to change and it
will it will change not overnight but in
an evolutionary in an evolutionary way
professor Lester wanted to comment on
that those kinds of changes don't seem
to me at least to be changes that you
can legislate this is not
the kind of thing that government can
can pass laws about these are
attitudinal changes sometimes quite
fundamental changes that will have to
take place over a long period of time
and involve all segments of society not
just or even primarily government I know
you have a lot more questions but we
said we would stop right now
let me just close this briefing by
giving you a point of view on this
question let us not forget that this
nation is a little bit different than
other nations it is not homogeneous it
has in it people from every possible
land and it has proven in the past that
it can adapt to change when it comes to
culture I personally do not believe that
the cultural differences are behind what
we have seen here you see the new me
plant where American workers are doing
just as well as the Japanese workers in
terms of the defects or the cars that
come out and so forth so I think that
the five imperatives list what are the
themes that have to be done this nation
has enough youthfulness in it enough
diversity in its various ethnic and
cultural groups to be able to cope with
it and if we pull together government
industry and educational institutions we
believe that it can be done thank you
very much